you may wonder why gina davis doesn't
work as much in front of the camera not
only has she become more selective about
her roles davis is also a producer and
has founded a research institute and
film festival she's trying to change the
film industry for the better 1992's a
league of their own was a massive
success and gina davis credits the film
for helping her claim the feminist label
but throughout the 1990s davis worked on
a string of movies that couldn't
replicate the success of a league of
their own later that same year davis
appeared in the movie hero opposite
dustin hoffman which faltered despite
the strength of the cast in 1994 she
starred in the drama angie a film that
performed poorly at the box office and
failed to garner a positive response
from critics next up was speechless a
movie that starred davis as a political
speechwriter who falls in love with a
speechwriter working for a rival
campaign the film was panned by critics
and her next role certainly didn't help
to revive her career either in 1995
davis starred as morgan adams in
cutthroat island which critic daniel
barnes summed up as a chaotic jumble of
bad action juvenile comedy and chili
romance all wrapped in a cheesecloth of
limp lifeless pirate cliches appearing
in several films with mediocre reviews
was definitely a setback for davis
in recent years gina davis has found
that she has a better track record of
landing fulfilling roles in tv shows
than in films from 2000 to 2001 she had
her own series the gina davis show later
she starred as president allen in the
series commander-in-chief and she also
appeared on the first season of the
exorcist as angela rance and in 2019 she
played sandy devereaux sinclair on the
beloved netflix series glow davis says
that she enjoys working in tv but
investing so much time and energy into
shows that have been cancelled is
discouraging these roles turned out to
be short-lived the gina davis show and
commander-in-chief only lasted one
season apiece and glow was cancelled
after three seasons davis's final
appearance on the show turned out to be
the series finale davis told aarp i was
so bummed when abc's commander-in-chief
went off the air as president allen i
had a very short administration
unfortunately she's struggled to find a
long-running tv role
gina davis became a mother in her 40s in
2001 she married reza jarrahi and the
couple had their first child a daughter
in 2002 and in 2004 davis gave birth to
their twin sons eventually davis and
jerahi separated officially going their
separate ways in 2018 davis says that
she had always wanted to become a mother
but when she was younger she felt like
the timing just wasn't right now she
sees the benefits of having children
later in life and she feels that she
made the right decision davis told the
guardian i always felt lucky that i had
my kids late because i just feel like i
changed so much i always knew i wanted
kids but what i was doing waiting that
long i don't know but it's been great
and twins are fun
life
is pain
get used to it
gina davis hasn't retired from acting
but since 2004 she's taken up another
cause she currently runs the gina davis
institute on gender in media and she's
on a mission to create more roles for
women in hollywood davis explained to
vogue the reason i started this whole
research institute is because i found
out that people absolutely had no idea
that kids media was so gender biased and
before i watched it with my daughter i
was sure it was fine i was appalled to
learn the truth and i decided i was
going to bring it up in my daily life in
hollywood while davis was watching
children's shows with her daughter she
noticed that there were far more male
characters than female characters but
when she brought it up at meetings no
one seemed to realize the extent of the
problem our research shows there's a
major gender gap in kids media
male characters outweigh female
characters two to one
davis decided that analyzing the data
was the answer so she founded the
institute and spearheaded the largest
research project concerning gender
depictions in tv and movies ever
conducted the disappointing results
confirmed her suspicions women simply
didn't get enough representation she's
been focused on changing this issue ever
since if girls can see female characters
taking up half of the space then they
will think of that in their real life
a large part of gina davis's work with
the institute concerns gathering data on
gender disparities in the media plenty
of people are interested in this issue
so why doesn't davis spend more time
promoting her research she says that
she's more effective at pushing for
change behind the scenes davis told
interview we go meet with every studio
every guild every network every
production company and share it with
them privately i don't really bust
anybody publicly it's much more
efficient if i can impact the creators
and in an interview with glamour davis
explained that her goals for the
institute don't necessarily revolve
around raising awareness of the issue
with the public i give speeches and
interviews and we release data to the
public but the main goal is not to
educate the populace she feels that
public pressure isn't necessarily the
key to making change in the
entertainment industry instead she has
to go directly to the people in charge
who can make it happen
besides meeting with directors and
screenwriters to push for more female
representation on screen what else has
gina davis been up to that occupies so
much of her time she's also working on
initiatives to encourage more diversity
in hollywood and she's taking things
into her own hands bff is an exciting
one-of-a-kind initiative that will
champion women and diversity in all
aspects of film in 2015 davis co-founded
the bentonville film festival a
non-profit film festival that showcases
movies directed by women people of color
and members of the lgbtq community the
bentonville film foundation which hosts
the festival also provides ongoing
year-round support to filmmakers who are
generally underrepresented in hollywood
davis wants to give opportunities to
talented directors who might not get the
attention they deserve in mainstream
film circles davis told the guardian oh
we want to change the world our goal is
very simple the storytellers and people
on screen should reflect the population
which is half female and incredibly
diverse it's not like wow what a
far-fetched idea it just makes total
sense we're always looking for great
films that are you know inclusive that
reflect
society as it is happy male and very
diverse
over the course of her career gina davis
has gotten pickier about the roles she's
accepted before she commits to playing a
particular character she always asks
herself what the women in the audience
would think of that particular role she
wants to play characters who are
genuinely interesting and complex rather
than settling for parts that don't speak
to her but unfortunately she's finding
it difficult davis told interview i
really want to get some good parts now i
have so much experience i probably could
be better than ever i just want them to
come along every once in a while it's
okay if it takes two or three years for
something really good to come along but
i don't want to wait 10 years for
something great to come along it's
maddening it's so frustrating it's
completely embarrassing at this point
davis doesn't want to take a role just
for the paycheck but even if it means
waiting a long time in between movies
she's willing to stick to her principles
gina davis said that once she turned 40
she realized that she wasn't being
offered nearly as many roles as she was
before she told the guardian i fell off
the cliff i really did in the early
stages of my career i was blithely going
along thinking meryl streep jessica
lange and sally field they're all making
these great female-centric movies and
i'm getting these great roles really
tippy top roles so things must be
getting better for women but suddenly
the great roles were incredibly scarce
age discrimination is an unfortunate
reality in hollywood while some believe
that there are more roles in movies for
older actresses today than there used to
be davis explained to aarp that this is
a myth despite the efforts of actresses
like herself the problem persists
naturally davis is frustrated by this
but instead of simply retiring she's
still moving forward and looking for the
roles that she wants
in addition to acting gina davis is also
an athlete after learning new sports on
film sets she decided that she wanted to
train in archery she told people i
thought i want to take up a sport in the
real life way and not the movie version
because they can fake anything like my
character in a league of their own only
hit home runs so i would do a nice swing
but the props guys had a giant slingshot
to send the ball over the fence with so
i thought i want to see if i can really
learn something real it turned out i
actually was athletic so that's when i
took up all this other stuff davis began
working with a trainer and started
practicing for five hours per day six
days a week and she quickly found that
she was exceptionally talented at the
sport in fact she was so skilled that
she made it to the semifinals for the
2000 olympics in sydney she placed 24th
and just missed qualifying for the us
olympic team today davis no longer
competes in archery but she does still
practice when she has the time she also
took up another sport rowing
gina davis has consistently continued
working but her recent releases haven't
fared well in 2020 davis had a
supporting role as bobby in the crime
drama ava ava a skilled and lethal
assassin who works for a black ops
organization is responsible for carrying
out hits on high profile figures across
the globe but when one of her jobs takes
a dangerous turn suddenly the tables
turn and she's forced to confront her
mistakes and fight for her life the plot
was standard action movie fair but
neither critics nor audiences found it
particularly compelling in a review for
decider critic john cerba remarked ava
is a violent boilerplate borney thriller
without a single original bone in its
body file under waste of talent it
certainly didn't help that the movie was
released in the midst of the coven 19
pandemic chances are even fans of davis
did not know that it was coming out
gina davis is always open to
opportunities that allow her to work
behind the scenes if it means creating
an empowering movie or tv show while she
has not directed a movie davis has
certainly diversified her career behind
the scenes from consulting with
directors and encouraging them to
include more female characters in their
scripts to working as a producer on
various projects davis has worn many
hats in 2018 davis served as an
executive producer on the documentary
this changes everything which explores
gender bias within hollywood davis and
many other actors appear in the film to
share their experiences as actresses
davis unveils why she began researching
and tackling the issue on her own in
addition davis produced the series
mission unstoppable with miranda
cosgrove from 2019 through 2021 in
mission unstoppable cosgrove interviews
women working on innovative endeavors in
fields like science technology
engineering and math so it's easy to see
why davis wanted to get on board with
the show
gina davis hasn't given up on finding
interesting new roles and projects she
has an upcoming movie and a tv series
lined up and she'll also be venturing
into the world of reality tv with her
own series i can buy friday in which
she'll spend each episode learning
difficult new skills and attempting
challenging stunts judging by her
success at mastering athletic talents on
movie sets and becoming a legit archery
champion she probably won't have much
trouble one thing is for sure whether
davis is working her magic behind the
camera or on screen she's determined to
be a force for change in hollywood for
years to come check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
celebrities are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one